how about Brian I shot a commercial
yesterday what I'll have his great ice
it's a commercial for Sam Adams Samuel
Adams Boston lager beer and the whole
campaign is your lot to say but this
campus yeah yeah for sure I mean I will
air it on the show when it when it drops
should drop in November but you gotta
toast someone like they're holding the
whole slogans like stop and take him
home toasting
god you're nuts so like toast is so and
like who's made a big impact on your
life so when they called me for the
campaign they picked five comedians and
they go hey you know I'm talking to the
guys with the creative with Samuel Adams
he goes you're one of the five we paid
Baba and he goes you know the whole
campaign is toasting as someone who's
made a big impact in your life you know
and your career and your comedy career
and then go so think of someone well you
know we need to know by Friday this is
on Monday he was in we need oh by Friday
oh no I'm good I'm the guy I got home at
oh she was really uh hey guys I mean
everyone else is taking a Friday yo noon
and I'm gonna
it's Brian Cowen I guess all we love
Brian oh yeah I missed a no-brainer man
as far as my career Brian come's been
the most influence so here's okay well
well so they shoot like the commercial
thing just love whatever all my stuff
and then like what the end we have to
have Brian come and you toast him and
just you gotta tell Mike not scripted
just there's no script you just tell
thanks for what he's done for your
career and you guys toast and that they
can't family yeah no big deal I said
Brian's really bad with emotion so he's
probably to make a joke out of all this
so I don't know if that works for the
commercial he's like don't worry we'll
figure it now
so we shoot all day yesterday I was
shooting I searched you in a dilemma oh
you did I am oh wow
search you nuts all day shoot 11:00 a.m.
Brian comes around 5:00 or 6:00 5:15
yeah
then it's then you do the toast and it's
kind of you know it's it's a little
awkward because Brennan's got to tell me
he's gotta say there's nothing scripted
so he's got to just speak how important
Brian is yeah and so but you know work
worked like really close we don't do
that we just [ __ ] around and laugh and
it's rare that you stop for a second
look a man in the eyes and go
you know you mean a lot to me I love you
thank you it's a head so we're joking
around the entire day like I give Brian
like this pretty weird do you laugh and
then bribe your brain still worse with
emotions and that's well documented on
this show Merrill I was retiring crying
I lost my fine bangles you're gay man is
it all right God you the weeping giant
yeah but yes I tell Brian listen we
cheers and Brian and just goes Samuel
Adams huh hey guys don't reference the
beer guys like I don't know what else to
say but we went because you when you got
there we're [ __ ] around yeah I'm
messin around and went from that and
then the guys now be heartfelt like yeah
well we had so much trash to talk about
people cuz it what Brendan I do is we're
a couple yeah Kathy gossipers and we
love if you want to get me on the phone
faster than anything or whatever I've
got something to tell you I'll just get
a text got some dirt got some to do I
got some but you ain't you can't handle
it right hey Kareem hey man didn't know
know what to call faster hey what what
so talk what I wanna know
it's always about someone's downfall
they're so stupid
so he's some stupid I heard yeah
did you hear some [ __ ] Chatty Cathy's
they say that's like gossip is eyes in
our DNA that some women for sure women
but also men Kizza specially when you go
back you know Oh buddy laughs psyched
yeah can we go back in the day - that's
like you know when there's in a village
when this hierarchy lice they would talk
it also keeps people are sort of in line
he's also a bonding thing cuz they say
like [ __ ] like when men get the other
yeah you know really women for sure but
when they starts a game and they started
building
wells in Africa us it had an effect on
the women would walk down to the river
and as they were walking they would talk
and they would bond and so these
Westerners come and they go we're
building you don't think around the
river and it [ __ ] up the dynamic the
gossiped I never became too easy to do
things at the well interests no yeah
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
Oh [ __ ] dismiss it